what triggers you Thea for what any to
piss you off is there certain things
triggers like like there's certain
triggers like yesterday during my Shaw
is doing big ground breakdown Jim
brought up somewhere here at you at the
top of the charts yeah number one
amazing Jim brought up something where
we're Dana White bullied a fighter and
man it was a trigger when a chin I just
faked time dude I just got so a boy I'm
not when it comes to that he you know he
told Woodley once he realized there's
only one man who calls the shots and get
in line the better off he is gonna be
and they just [ __ ] home triggered me
like on this rant for [ __ ] 30 minutes
kind of [ __ ] up the show yeah didn't
[ __ ] I did it I mean didn't [ __ ] it up
and it really [ __ ] grinding my gears
this Peter Griffin says dang is there
certain things that do that to you yeah
when I when I don't when I don't do it
when I don't take care of myself really
is what does it not to go back to that
one when I don't take her myself but
what triggers me is when things seem
unfair I just deal when something feels
unfair it just makes me just mad man and
rich people sometimes drive me nuts
that just if their hair looks really
really nice or if their skin looks like
their skin has never seen yeah even the
wind like they were even as a child they
had people standing out in front of them
as block and yeah it just makes me mad
it just makes me mad it's because
they're not aware of other people live
and how how hard it is for some some
people yeah and when I see deadbeat dads
that makes me mad that'd be number one
for me I was just think they on Good
Morning America Phil Collins daughter
came out was like you know I know my I
had a deadbeat dad he's never around I
just want to say I forgive him like well
how do I feel clothes anymore Wow
[ __ ] that guy yeah that's Phil Collins I
goddamn it his dollars like you know I
did resent him forever cuz he's never
around was basically missing my entire
childhood oh my god damn it especially
as a dad you know bad that [ __ ] that
get up yeah she had to go through all
this therapy and all this shenanigans
I was celebrity children seemed like the
war like it's got like a top see look
look did you see some of the celebrity
kids like if you look at like how
they're doing I'm talking
celebrities are not doing that well most
of them have a hard time yes they did
they're tough because the expectations
I'll tell you the kids that do well
again it just depends but now in the NFL
and then being they can most of them
it's like 85% we have a relative who
played professional sports Wow yeah
there's there's a yeah that's in their
genes like especially now it's like 85%
have some sort of connection to a
relative that's awesome yeah I think
that what happens is with a lot of they
did a documentary called rich kids I
think it's called and I took some the
kids from the richest families man oh
man are they not doing well you know the
shat I know we keep dropping stats
remember price so whilst I'm funny but
you're 400% more likely to die before
the age of 30 if you come from rich
pants yeah Wow Wow struggle you need to
be a little afraid of when your next
dollars coming from yeah I think at the
end of the day you blame the parents
though right because the parents are
give them everything in the beanie
enablers when you hop though right
because when your parents like I talked
to some very wealthy people in London
one time and they were all talking about
they all made so much money they all had
young kids and they were all talking
about this thing called the handicap of
wealth and the conversation of the table
for two hours was how do we get our kids
to not be victims of the fact that we
have made all this money and don't make
it work you know how to make Jerry
Seinfeld time Society said his daughter
goes you got to make him work like most
of them they don't work because the
parents have so much money like why the
[ __ ] about where's my allowance
they say that none more thing you do is
like yeah I get a job a little homie
like Jerry Seinfeld talks about he said
he was driving his daughter to work and
one of us you know he has 500 car shoes
you dropped me off in a new car every
[ __ ] time she discussed this to me
exactly so he dropped me off in a car
every [ __ ] day like the kids are
making fun of me yeah well you want me
to switch my life stuff cause kids are
making fun of you
she was yeah dad he goes cuz we're rich
and he goes boom I'm rich
you gotta make your own [ __ ] yeah like
this is my arm rich don't get it twisted
sweetie turn 16 you have to figure some
[ __ ] I fell ur
rockefeller told his kids he had so much
money cuz here's here's rockefeller no
rockefeller
rich richest rich and one of the richest
American fans Larry rocking families and
he had he had four boys I think one who
ended up being eaten in the Amazon they
think by my tribe but he said he said to
all of them now door brothers if you
gotta say you know they were Indians
they or not they were they were bad
outdoor Aborigines and he said to all of
these sons and his children said here's
the good news you're rich here's the bad
news you have a big responsibility to
change the world there are no excuses
now since you don't have to worry about
making ends meet you you can now you
will now go to ought to be a governor
one of his sons of the governor another
son went off to be a huge anthropologist
until he lost his life on an exploratory
mission another one so he held them to
such a high standard which is with
wealth comes great responsibility
you can better make that you better make
an impact on the world do you think that
whenever you die your well should go
back into some sort of a pool so that
they don't I think it should be you
should it's you should be allowed to do
with that wealth what you want you
worked for it you should be able to
bestow it to your children to a charity
it should be all up to you yeah and I
think they agree I think I think the
smart thing to do with that is if you
have a wealth you don't give it to the
kid when he's 21 25 I mean when he turns
like 40 you should have access to the
money because by then he knows who he is
he's gonna establish himself for this
for you I would give because you're if I
if you were my son and I had that money
you're a good example of a guy who knows
exactly what to do with money I would a
hundred percent give get have given you
money at 30 or maybe earlier because I
don't think you're the kind of guy that
would spend it so that's an animal I'm
just saying if your son let's say if he
knows he's gonna in here ten million
dollars you gotta make sure you makes
him you know makes a path for himself
makes a life for himself because then
that ten million dollars when he's 40s
kids and a wife he can buy his dream
home and not [ __ ] stress I'm up in 20
percent down or he can go live somewhere
where he's always dreamed to live like
he's gonna have you know this access
that he's always wanted you know maybe
he's and but he still have to make a
life for himself not just some dumbass
huffing and jackin off the nyquil in
Jesus Christ you're right full circle
parents also have to keep their
you have to let your children know that
if you have a lot of money that they are
so [ __ ] lucky and they should be able
to see that's so what other I guess I
was lucky I'll be talking about being
poor you know I'm saying like a rich I
can't write procedes talk about the
struggles of being poor now you have to
see yeah you have to live it because if
you go hey you know the kids not out
there that get Jordans like cool dad
all I know is Jordans it's hard to
accept in the shoes you can't hold that
against me no you can't but you can but
you if you see it sometimes like as a
kid maybe I was I just was grew up
around real poverty seeing it I always
say I saw it from the inside of an
air-conditioned car yeah and I did
whether it was in Africa whether it
wasn't in Pakistan whether was in Yemen
where there was some parts of Saudi
Arabia whether it was in you know India
yeah I saw it and and you see shanty
towns and when you see how people really
live in those places Indonesia what
happens is if you're if you're lucky
you'll feel guilty right and you'll feel
a little ashamed how did you grow up
deal because I know I saw you mentioned
you know earlier like I never had that
about love or something like that like
yeah I don't know my smile my dad was
really old when I was born my dad was 70
was an old man
he's lost about this the other day on
because I've got to do Rogen's podcasts
I was you know interesting I was just
talking about that in the podcast
universe but how do you really say yeah
you don't have to go I'm just curious
like ya know my mother delivered
newspapers still does deliver newspapers
which is kind of odd for an adult got a
Netflix special still yet your mom would
deliver newspapers yeah well right dude
I don't know money she wants to work
that she won't stop where she just she
got a van with no windows in it now
that's what she wanted which i think is
extremely dangerous for somebody really
near and senior citizenship no back when
is it his front inside but no back no
back and no side it's like a huge white
van you like one of those Australian
looking van
no at the high top yeah she's in about
dude and she and she delivers new paper
yeah it was out of that and that's good
right arm on her bro she could and she's
a whip Thomas
yeah oh sure whip they're classified -
new ass are you close with your mama
yeah we're pretty close I always thought
I was like a daddy's boy I guess cuz I
didn't have my dad so it was like this
dream in my head yeah but I'm realizing
more like a mama's boy
yeah because your dad was absent because
he was older and passed away yeah he
just got old man he was just doing old
[ __ ] ease to rest a lot and well [ __ ]
when you were 21 he'd been 91 yeah he
was he when he we should pretend he was
a fire I remember sitting around a movie
just put our hands on will his rest and
return he was a fire because that was
how he could play with us like as a kid
you know you use adults for I guess what
you could imagine them being yeah so we
were tending he was a furnace or we
pretended he was uh we couldn't touch
him that was like one of the games
couldn't touch him and we would get real
close he passed away away what age 86 he
was 86 sure he was 16 when you present
yeah yeah yeah and he was I mean he was
a neat man oh so I got to know him
better you know now that sex is 16 you
really don't appreciate it yeah you know
you still learn a lot of stuff but I'm I
learned a shitload from my dad from like
18 to like 25 when I bit you do you
think you're growing up you get kinda in
the real world and you deal with some
real issues that's where your dad comes
into play that was very very involved in
both of your hands on this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]